to present the Award for Best Actor an
Academy award-winning actress miss Greer
Garson
this is hardly the time to be worthy but
if anybody would still like to be I I
think I had ten minutes left over from a
highly emotional speech I made a few
years ago I'd be glad to give it to them
that that was before they had these new
and disappear Tory noise reduction
devices we heard about tonight
now the nominees are Humphrey Bogart in
the African Queen verizon enterprises
incorporated United Artists Marlon
Brando in a streetcar named desire
Charles cattlemen group productions
Warner Brothers Montgomery Clift
in a place in the Sun paramon Arthur
Kennedy in bright victory Universal
International and Frederic March in
Death of a Salesman Stanley Kramer
company Columbia the message please the
winner is Humphrey Bogart this is sort
of a cloud night for her
Bogey's coming down that aisle
manager stairway to paradise enthusiasm
as you can tell and it's a second
nomination and the Spurs Oscar
be and is receiving a very nice
regards we will
she received the Oscar it's it's a very
long way from the heart of the Belgian
Congo the stage of the Pantages Theater
and I'm very glad to say that it's a
little nicer here and it was there I I
just want to pay a slight as a matter of
fact a very big tribute mr. John Huston
and miss Katherine Hepburn because they
helped me to be where I am now thank you
very much